you
[Music]
all right welcome everybody it is chess
night in America and around the world we
have ourselves a tournament I promised
it I have delivered and we are here I
invite everybody who wants to play to
play it's free it's all skill levels
welcome this is not like a you know
membership thing it's open to everybody
you can just watch me play if you want
or you can play at david pakman.com
slash chess that will redirect you to
david pakman show to arena starting in
16 minutes and i think this is going to
be a great tournament my goal is that we
get over 500 players the first time we
did this on a complete whim we had right
around 500 players I don't actually
remember the exact number but I want to
just blow past it so I'm inviting you to
play and actually play david pakman.com
slash chess we have 363 people set up to
play today we have 5 people rated over
two thousand one provisionally and then
we've got you know a bunch of people
1,900 1,800 but then on the tail end of
it we have people in the 600's and the
700s and and and this is all great i
mean everybody's welcome you don't have
to worry about being matched against
people way better than you because the
system will basically match you against
people roughly of your skill level and
there will be eventually there will be a
winner so absolutely join in and
participate i am going to be reading
super chats and responding to twitch
subscription messages like for example
jimmy tenpins just asked when we can
expect the first 4d chess tournament
yeah trump's gonna be running back very
very soon
rinoa has subscribed on twitch and says
happy to have my hubby along for the
tournament absolutely and we are it's
all just so exciting
and I've got people sending me messages
asking why I banned them I you know we
have moderators I have no idea this is
not the time for that very very
inopportune time I should say to be
asking me questions like that I'm not
involved in the banning I would say and
what else is there to discuss we had a
great program on the broadcast oh I just
touched base with Stephen Kenneth
destiny banal ii he told me he is going
to be play playing also a game streamer
named hutch that some of you may know
from twitch he expressed interest in
playing I mean I sent him a message let
me see if he got back to me he didn't he
wanted to play but in any case if in the
next 15 minutes any of you want to go to
some major chest streamers and recruit
them to come play in this tournament I
would love it I think it would be huge
huge exposure if we were to get some
some big big chest streamers
participating here but if not it doesn't
matter we're going to have an absolutely
fantastic time so if you're just joining
you've got about 14 minutes before the
tournament starts david.com / chess or I
also put the link in the description on
YouTube and on Twitch so if you're
watching on Facebook just go to david
pakman.com slash chess it'll redirect
you to the Lee chess tournament and we
currently have 371 people registered to
play I'm fired up I have to tell you I
am very very very fired up when people
say am I even ranked I don't know what
what does it mean if am i ranked I mean
my you know I'm 1323 that's me I don't
know what what you're talking about
thanks to the Italian stallion who
subscribed with prime and says who's
gonna win the tournament tonight well my
guess is it's going to be someone who's
relative from the standpoint of ratings
I would say it's probably going to be
someone relatively highly rated I think
the only titled player that played last
time was Eric Rosen and I don't see him
subscribed right now
people asking whether Hasan [ __ ] will
play I have no idea he's welcome to play
I would love to have him here over on
YouTube HS DTE sends a super chat and
says please tell him of Lee I lover M of
Lee alright M of Lee HS DTE loves you
Daniel Rivera says reach out to Garry
Kasparov Grandmaster and quite political
I would love to I just don't know that I
can't right now and Captain Crunch says
David you need to watch Trump is not
well video here on YouTube by the
Lincoln project I saw it says it's good
good luck on the tournament very very
important we do have a hype train
happening right now over on Twitch
there's just so much going on all at
once and symbolic gamer has subscribed
and says good luck alluring Lord says I
don't even know how to play chess I'm
just here for David soothing tones thank
you
when aveer has signed up and Gordo
side-to-side jumps there's so many
people checking in which I love
Azim Abu Khalil sends a super chat and
says can the development of a
consistently effective non-lethal
substitute for the firearm serve as a
solution to the problem of gun violence
generally well I think it would be an
interesting element but I don't know
that it is a solution in total I see
people continuing to ask how to sign up
for the tournament david pakman.com
slash chess 383 people registered right
now Oh someone just withdrew we're back
down to only 380 to help us get past 500
we had 500 people who played last time
were at 382 and I would love love love
love to blow that out of the water I do
want to say thanks to Darrel Maxwell and
Michael Cullinan
they are new members 1 & 2 today at join
pakman.com you guys didn't think that
new members weren't going to get thanked
right I mean any any opportunity I don't
know I have no idea whether people are
going to want to sign up but all of this
stuff we do is all supported by people
just sign up on the website we've got a
coupon code I won't say much about it
this is a fun social event but by all
means you can support all the work we do
including the viral videos we we
actually had our best 48 hours on
YouTube over the last 48 hours maybe
that we've ever had
we had one clip get 300,000 another got
180 another one got 100 the YouTube
channel has been going crazy the last 48
hours so this is just a reminder that it
all is supported by memberships on the
website we did get a feed a master
social Isilon e who just joined raided
2300 very very exciting as we now are
approaching 400 players registered for
the tournament with just 9 minutes and
50 seconds to go
amazing amazing in all seriousness
though consider yourselves invited thank
you to everybody who is hanging on
Twitch let's see here see swerve 420 has
subscribed on Twitch anonymous gift er
has gifted a subscription to Hillary
Clinton which we love a lot of action
happening people asking about whether Oh
Eric might play ok cool Eric might join
when there's 6 minutes left and when
people asking if desk destiny I just
talked to destiny and he said I've said
are you playing tonight he said yes when
is it and how long and what is it and I
said it's a chess tournament that's it
just it that's all it is so oh Aaron
Wysocki beautiful I wonder if Aaron's
playing
I hope our Aaron's an a long time friend
and Aaron is the guy to go to for
hilarious parenting stories let's just
let's just put it that way and leave it
at that all right 394 people are
registered I would love to get beyond
500 oh just give me one second I do need
to ban some anti-semitism it's like
we're playing chess and the
anti-semitism
continues coming in it's crazy aniket
Patel says thanks for the chess
tournament Pakman Daniel Rivera says new
account from all that cheating ha just
kidding Oh Aaron tell you that is Aaron
cool Aaron texting me yeah this is not
the first time we've done this by the
way Aaron we had 500 people play last
time I'm hoping to get I mean listen I
was hoping to get to a thousand but I
don't know that it's necessarily gonna
happen today but we are almost at 400
which is fantastic absolutely fantastic
we do have seven players rated 2,000 or
above and we also have a bunch of people
rated six seven eight hundred which i
think is really great people continuing
to ask for the link okay I'm gonna do
this two times two places to find the
tournament david pakman.com slash chess
that will redirect you or there's a link
in the description on YouTube and on
twitch okay we have a level 4 hype train
happening on Twitch as well Oh people
suggesting I put it in the title all
right let's see david pakman.com slash
chess done beautiful thanks to Drew Noah
for gifting some subscriptions yeah it's
like guys we're just trying to have a
good time and you know the anti-semitic
chatting is just very very toxic we
don't ever tolerate it but certainly on
chess night in America we are not going
to tolerate that okay let's see what
else we've got going on here
people asking if I will take calls after
the tournament the tournament hasn't
even started and people are already
displeased I will take calls if we get
50 members or patrons let me put it that
way this is going to be an intense
tournament so I don't know that that's
necessarily going to happen has destiny
signed up yet I have no idea I have no
idea what Destiny's username is on Lee
chess and
couldn't tell you destiny said he was
playing and I believe that he will I
mean what else can I tell you thank you
to this strange quark as well very much
appreciated we are in the middle of a
level 5 hype train coming in very very
hot
Jorge xerostomia says very disappointing
you won't take my portray on money for a
deep hack destiny podcasts at Jorge I
don't know what you're talking about
I'm sorry my friend I have no idea what
you're talking about I won't take your
money thanks to Luke Knapp whose new
member number 3 today on my website very
much appreciate that we are down if
you're just joining us we're down to the
last five minutes before the start of
the tournament you can play this is free
it's it's free it's just free there's no
there's no ask here david pakman.com
slash chess or look at the description
on youtube or on twitch we are at 423
players right now I would love to get
beyond 500 before the start of the
tournament I think we can do it we're
just five minutes away people asking if
producer Pat is playing he said he is
going to be playing I think that his
username on Lee chesses I thought it was
TDPS Pat or maybe it's producer Pat yeah
but he said he was going to play which i
think is going to be a very very
exciting development Daniel Rivera says
what do the tournament winners get as an
award you get a you get a digital trophy
like it's literally an image of a trophy
on LY chess and I will congratulate you
that's basically it people asking a lot
of weird questions very personal
questions that have no they're neither
here nor there
we're just 63 players from 500 oh sorry
Pat is texting me Pat Forde 94 is
producer Pat and he is I believe he's
even ranked higher than I am we were
talking earlier because he's still on a
provisional ranking where is Pat Forde
94
let's see here having trouble finding
him there's just so many people who
signed up to play so they have a
provisional 1500 rating which is fine
this is this is for everybody it's it's
open to all we have one titled player
right now and a whole page of people
over 1900 people
Oh people are asking on Li Ches if I'm
streaming yes I am streaming people
uh-oh are there any right wingers
playing that's an interesting question
are there any right wingers who are
playing who hate my political views but
are still participating that's an
interesting question
thanks to Cameron Bundy Cameron is new
member number four today at join
pakman.com we are down to the last three
minutes before this starts we are just
50 players away from 550 players away
what was that Oh people are sending the
challenges on Leach s yeah I'm not um
I'm not accepting challenges right now
because I'm in the middle of a
tournament or about to be anyway let's
see what else we've got here
oh it's david pakman.com slash chess not
david pakman show comm slash chess all
right so that's definitely something -
something to bear in mind I will say 43
more players and we will be at 500
everybody's welcome I see a lot of
confusion how can you be allowed to play
the link is david pakman.com slash chess
there's no you you're just allowed to
play that's it you don't need me to do
anything to allow you in there's a link
if you're watching on youtube there's a
link if you're watching on Twitch and we
have 2 minutes to go and 32 more players
will get us to 500 let's do it Oh his
destiny the Destiny show up he said he
was going to play I didn't see him show
up the
27 players to go in the last two minutes
to see if we can kick off with 500
players 25 to go david pakman.com slash
chess is the place to do it
Oh Destiny's eating can someone tell him
the tournament is starting this is crazy
he I just was texting with him and he
said he was going to play
hey we start in 90 seconds
I heard you are eating on stream holy
shet 20 players to go and we will be at
500 our initial goal destructive animal
sent me a super chat saying Kasparov is
a right-wing anti-socialist Karpov is a
Putin friend Fischer was an anti-semitic
lunatic that is true being a chess fan
and a progressive is hard sometimes
there's actually a lot of progressives
in the twitch chess community we have
one minute to go and we are looking for
21 more players at david pakman.com
slash chess 19 players to go 19 players
to go and we are getting right down to
the wire need to have a little more of
my water 14 players to go 13 to go I
think we might do it guys this is
amazing tend to go no Bobby Fischer was
Bobby Fischer I didn't think Bobby
Fischer was Jewish he was anti-semitic
but I don't think he was a so-called
self-hating Jew I believe yeah anyway we
have 20 seconds to go and we are 7
players from 507 players from 500 my
chance to win half 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 0
all right here we go David Pakman show
second tournament ever and we are off oh
boy and Danny too let's see if I can fix
this as my opponent has not started
playing yet there we go
ok good
my opponent is about to forfeit because
they have not started playing I think
that's okay though that'll get me to
somebody else
back to tournament and we will continue
there we go sorry I didn't have think
now we're framed correctly so I guess I
missed that first game because my player
my opponent just didn't show up uh here
we go all right off we go
looks like a bunch of people already won
a game I don't know how that's possible
here Oh Ranga I feel like I played
against hero Rango last time is that
possible we are very much often running
here by the way don't cheat okay guys
please please no cheating in this
tournament we are often running my
friends you can still play
david pakman.com slash chess still very
much able to get in anytime during the
tournament no big deal
playing against hero ranga as a bunch of
people have already won games
let's see typically here i've actually
had this position a bunch of times
and of course my memory is just not good
enough for me to know how i should be
playing it right
uh okay think I'm gonna develop here
let's see what we can do here
people are stream sniping I don't even
know what that means what does it mean
to stream snape can someone explain that
to me then call castle interesting
yeah guys I don't know what stream
sniping is I'm sorry I'm just not I just
don't know hmm need to come up with
something here this I'm gonna take here
this is not a position that I recall
having had before hmm thinking for
whatever reason that I might want to go
in this direction although I don't know
that actually helps me stream sniping is
watching someone streaming while they're
in the same game is you to look at your
location and okay I got it I think I
understand no
what am i doing I just gave away my
queen all right that was a disaster
oh my god what am i doing that was a
mental mistake more than anything
hmm that was a huge mistake and now kind
of stuck here here we go that was a
major blunder but first blunder of the
evening my friends major major blunder
but that's okay I mean listen we're in
this for fun that's the whole point of
all of it
there any reason not to take this pawn
think I'm going to take it and then I
think this is a free Bishop
I believe that that was the right move
there so here here doesn't doesn't
really work but I think I may have to I
think I have to take it I don't know
that there's any simple way to protect
now I've got to be worried back here
this is now getting dicey no hmm this is
actually pretty complex for me now let
me see what is the right move I think
just this for now it's sort of like a
waiting move
I think maybe now I protect that pawn
maybe
interesting I think maybe get on the
open file here I think I'm gonna take it
and then here not this pawn is not
protected this is really getting down
there a huge mental mistake when I lost
my Queen yeah that was a horrible
horrible moment absolutely horrible
so if I go here and here yeah it's not
looking good it's not looking good
that's for sure
this is Harry yeah people are absolutely
correct this is very very hairy I mean
when I gave away my queen that was sort
of like when it went bad yeah I think I
think I'm out resigning just just big
maasai has made a mistake I mean what
can you do we do have five hundred and
forty two players amazing that's
fantastic and we will see who I get
matched with next thanks to everybody
watching on Facebook YouTube and twitch
this is the second David Pakman show
chess tournament it's just fun if that
that's all it is let's see who I'm going
to be playing against next some people
already with four points on fire and
people asking about how to join david
pakman.com slash chess david pakman.com
slash chess all right here we go in a
try not to I mean I gave away my queen
you know it's like what can I do that's
just that's bad
alright usually I've had this before
I remember some of the moves
I think this is not what I'm used to
playing against thank you there's a
potential I just see if this is what I
wanted to do yeah I think so
I've had this position and one big li
I've also had this position and and made
some mistakes and lost let's see what's
going on
does Conda mighty have the book
knowledge I certainly don't I certainly
don't that we know for sure is this a
free night I think it is a free night I
think unless I'm missing something
hmm this is getting ugly so just this
makes sense not really I don't think so
I think I'm actually more interested
here and then possibly this and then
maybe here yeah
actually am I better off I think I'm
better off taking the Queen see what
happens here
yeah do I just I mean I think so right
here is this the move
hmm so let me think about this if I go
here if takes then I take or maybe I
just take here wait let me think about
that if I take and then I still I think
either way wait let me think about that
here here here I think this is better
yeah I think everybody can still join
david pakman.com slash chess yes
everybody's wide open you can join up
until the very end no big deal
so now here if here than there actually
don't know what to do now if I take the
Queen actually I think I take the Queen
this way what am i doing
here and then I think back here
maybe here and then I think right here
where is checkmate though oh I think
it's here there we go all right back to
tournament let's see if we can make up
for that first horrible loss where I
gave away my queen some people already
with eight points my goodness and
somehow did this person already play six
games that's crazy
that is crazy anybody know - destiny
make it in I hope that he did
thanks to 503 Phoenix and tide well for
the twitch subscriptions really
appreciate it very very much appreciate
it
alright I think now I'm about to get
absolutely crushed this seems to be
somebody who's a gay who's a who's a
real player at least I got that one win
at least I got one win stephen is
playing right now okay good ah yeah
I don't remember what the right move is
here if here here here I think that's
what I usually play hmm no I take I've
had this position before
Stephens banning people oh cool alright
good for Stephen you know drop the ban
hammer I believe here I've gotten into
trouble with this because now I remember
why I don't normally play this position
this way yeah let's try try something
let's just see what happens cuz this is
interesting right here if not played
correctly although this is probably too
good of a player to fall for it the key
to winning chess is voting in November
says here Oh shadow via YouTube super
chat I very much agree with that I
completely agree with that
alright so let's see ghost of Mark Twain
is thinking that's at least something Oh
destinies playing super fast okay I got
it
um let me think about this
here here here now that doesn't really
work doesn't really work now hold on a
second let's just see this put some
pressure right away let's try this let's
see what happens
has to have to do something here right I
mean otherwise this could get very ugly
very very quickly yes if you can still
get you can still join david pakman.com
slash chess you can still join it's
actually interesting so let's see yeah
I'm not I don't even want to think ahead
cuz I just I doubt that they're going to
fall for this let's see what happens
thinking is good thinking is good
taking a while all right that's
interesting um okay so let's see where
do we want to go next
hmmm I think back here and then maybe
we'll put more pressure on this square
and see if we can get something going
there well people want to see my rank
okay geez let's see my rating I think
you mean there we go beautiful we got it
alright I'm up a minute now end up a
pawn if I can avoid blundering this oh
my entire computer just briefly froze
all players are welcome this is the
second David Pakman show chess
tournament ever Oh a bunch of people are
sending me messages okay let's see I
think so I think let's see
so if here Queen moves but then I've got
a discovered check I think I'm gonna go
for this or do I go with check you know
I'm gonna have to analyze this let's see
what this looks like later I'm actually
not sure what the right move was there I
do want to analyze that maybe it was
neither of these moves but I want to see
so if I take and then here what is the
right move here I don't want to mess
this up because this is a good position
it could also just take here leave the
tension no I think I'm going to take
here and then depending
oh the Knights pinned yeah very good
point Steven Kenneth destiny bonel is
shot out of a cannon right now oh that's
interesting I didn't know that okay so
is it the right move just to take here I
think it is I hope this isn't a blunder
tight on time now as well and we've got
this can't take here because of that
okay so do I go with check think I'd go
with check and keep the time pressure up
then maybe try to castle out of the way
I think I'm gonna oh I can't castle
Jesus oh boy this is actually not as
simple as I thought let's go back to
another check Oh hold on a second let's
see if we can get in position for a
discovered check I think we can oh wait
no right I can't but we've got to get
out of the way man now I'm low on time
this one's getting tight got to try to
move here and there's the check and then
here takes here could we get it this
one's a squeaker into the corner maybe
and then here boom wow wow that was
close
whew that was a tight one I want to end
up which game that was the second one
Oh Eric Rosen's now playing that's cool
we've got 595 players right now stunning
stunning stunning stunning if you liked
that oh people liking that win that one
I think deserves a sub I think that that
win was I pulled that one out of who
knows where I think that one is that I'm
sweating after that one need a drink of
water oh boy
wow that was close that was very very
close alright here we go again let's see
what we've got okay usually here I
actually get very confused in these
positions very very often all right
let's pin the night at least for now on
this sometimes I'll take some yeah
sometimes I'll go back I think I'm gonna
go back actually you know what I'm gonna
take I'm worried about getting the
bishop stuck back here thanks to rob
seven seven four seven for the twitch
Prime subscription you know it's
occurring to me to just block right here
since it's defended but maybe that'll
come a little bit later yeah I'm looking
for a Power Move for sure if you're just
joining us this is not a political
stream this is the second ever David
Pakman show chess tournament maybe
Bishop here you can play at david
pakman.com slash chess if you would like
if you would like
I think I'm going to castle so now this
is not looking quite so good let me
think sort of not loving some of what's
going on
I this occurs to me to just try to take
this square away from the Queen and to
block this I think I'm going to go for
that I don't know if that's a good move
but I think I'm going for it and then
mmm this is where I don't know what to
do I think I might start moving some
pawns up we have this under control
I think I mean that this would be very
very dumb I don't can't imagine that's
what's coming what is my opponent trying
to do
don't know if there's really a point to
taking here I do like this this and this
I think I'm going to try that
yeah people asking me if I know destiny
is playing I did know he was playing at
it by now I've heard that he's playing
this is an interesting one
now if takes here oh that's interesting
hmm actually I'm not sure what to do
here here Oh actually I think I like
this idea because it's a potential fork
so yeah let's let's just see what
happens this would be a beautiful move
for me I'll actually know what wouldn't
because this square is defended right
here what am I talking about this is why
I'm not so good
Queens got a move the question is where
checkers is definitely harder than chess
yeah absolutely definitely there goes
the Queen so this is defended um where
do we want to go now actually unsure I
think I might try to get the Queen
activated where I think here actually
and then the pawn is not defended
actually I think I'm gonna take here
this would be checked but then either
piece can take is there any advantage to
it maybe just attack the Queen directly
wait a second now hold on no I think
this is okay actually I think this is
okay I'm a little low on time oh I see
Matt Wallace you signed up I will we're
gonna we're gonna tally you up
momentarily Matt Oh Destiny's sending me
messages on discord this is not the time
for that my friend let's see where does
the Queen go where does the Queen go
okay I think where do I go now hmm
genuinely unsure here maybe check and
then take here if the bishop takes and
then I've got some action so I take okay
that's I think that's a free queen right
did I did I did he did a blunder or did
I do something wrong but I didn't see
their okay so maybe check and then if
here check here I think I just take take
again I think this is me right boom
beautiful beautiful all right let's get
right back to it keep it going
29th right now 29th out of 621 this is
the best I've ever done stunning um
thank you to Matt Wallace who is new
member number five today at join
pakman.com we have Eric Rosen streaming
the tournament Lord overlay is streaming
as well that's all very very interesting
here is a provisionally ranked player
let's let's get going and see what's
happening here all right usually this is
how I play Queens game this is Queens
gambit right yes I did play a boat s
gambit that's exactly right I gave away
my queen okay and what do I usually do
here I think this
here usually I like to get a little
action going here when given the
opportunity anyway still plenty of time
for people who want to jump in on this
I've only played I think three or four
games and actually I kind of been
preferring this right now david
pakman.com slash chess is available to
you you can join we had at last count I
believe 652 players which is way more
way way way more than we had last time
which is just fantastic I'm looking at
at least temporarily pinning here okay
right so now I guess I just go back okay
so now I've got to be careful because of
this here
maybe just here not feeling super strong
about this I think I take here not
feeling super-confident about this very
interested in this square but probably
not yet hmm
do I want to play here mmm then if they
move I'm really unsure here this is
getting dicey for me I'm onna people are
asking me who else is streaming this
I know Destiny's playing and it said
that Erik that the Alicia says Eric
Rosen and one other person are streaming
on Lee chess Sam Dean coming in out of
nowhere with a super chess as nice
playin bro full full respect from osmate
okay what do we have going on here um
maybe I just put pressure on the Queen
can't move here can't move here can't
move here oh no no no no that's a bad
idea
that would have been a disastrous idea
good thing I didn't do that um I think
what is the right move here might just
castle
castle yeah that that diagonal is not a
great diagonal for me I want to go here
think I kind of liked the idea of
getting this night off the board if they
play ball oh that did not account for
that so that was a mistake
that was a huge mistake hmm I think I
have to go here
yep I think so that was not a good that
was not a good play that was definitely
that's got to be a mistake maybe not a
blunder but certainly a mistake and I'm
low on time as well
hmm interesting maybe an opportunity to
catch up on time so I think I have to
take the bishop right yeah I think so
and then I think
I think I want to get a little more
action here
yeah I can tell that there was
definitely this was suboptimal
suboptimal it was just not good oh oh
boy alright I think we're gonna go nope
getting short on time here got to make
some kind of decision
I'll take here actually I like the idea
of taking with this night there we go
I'm gonna have to make something happen
here then here you'll have to move could
take here and then check really getting
down to the wire here think I will take
here and then over here that was not a
good idea let's just see what happens
gonna have to come here that was a
mistake we're gonna have to analyze this
one folks
not good I guess I take here and that
might be it
that might be it might have to come over
here for now here
this is a tight one but I've got a check
right here and then check here and then
check here then check here I think I
have no more checks get to the open file
now it's a scramble oh boy not looking
good not looking good let's see if we
can get some pawns going got to stay
away from the rook don't want to end up
in a fork situation hmm
Oh what am i doing that was it that was
that that was a blunder too much time
pressure
I'll take upon I guess but way way way
too much time pressure there I'll try to
get up here not good not good not good
not good
it was a valiant effort I might as well
resign but we're gonna keep it going
just briefly yep that's it all right
well it was a valiant effort it was a
valiant effort but that was just too big
of a mistake way way way too big of a
mistake somebody with 24 points already
stunning absolutely stunning all right
we're going right back into it yep that
was just I did not play well it was it
was okay until the end let me say thanks
to Dan Ashgar who just grabbed the
membership at join pakman.com and his
new member number six today very very
exciting very much appreciate the
support of all sorts of great people you
know you really here I kind of just play
aggressive and go this way
let's see what we've got there's
actually some interesting there's an in
this is there's this gambit I'm trying
to remember it where this can go like
horribly horribly wrong I'm just trying
to remember exactly what it is
I'm thinking very very strongly right
now
about what exactly there's a mistake
here where was that I think it might be
here no I don't remember sadly and I'm
down to pons now for nothing because I
just didn't remember that's too bad
this is interesting
does this work
I think this works right
I mean is there there's takes or there's
doesn't take right I don't know is there
a check that they've got no so I guess
there's the Queen and then I should
probably get the hell out of here yeah
we're gonna go back here now we've just
got to start developing I'm Way behind
on development here okay
like I'm looking at this here yeah
pinned the night there I don't think
that's a terrible idea
here fight leave it I think I'm actually
gonna leave it and take with the night
if takes yeah welcome to everybody this
is live you can play at david pakman.com
slash chess i've lost some games i've
won some games yeah so we're gonna keep
here and then still pinned which was the
whole point of this so check HERE don't
know that that does too much for me what
about here then here then back I don't
love that either I think I'm gonna take
and then here let's see what they go
with this is more thinking than I'm used
to have to use used to have to doing
I mean I guess I'll take the pond for
now now could this work as if here and
then here then here I don't think it
works there any fork possibility I think
I'm gonna bring the night out and see
what happens
there's this free pond but just trying
to get some development done here
I don't know how Pat's doing in the
tournament that's a good question we
should investigate that it's a very very
fair question still 29 minutes to go
right so I should have not allowed that
that was definitely a mistake now I
can't castle either I guess I just go
right at it right let's see cuz if here
yeah I think I have to go right at the
night that was a mistake that was a
mistake I think I take and then check
and then take here
is there any advantage to another check
I don't think so I think I'm just gonna
take here would this cheque be useful
not sure by the way let's just wait on
that now avoided it
what about check and if takes I take is
that something I should be looking at I
think I will given the situation and
that I don't want to get too far down
did I miss Mayton one oh boy if I miss
Mayton one I'm gonna have to I'm gonna
try to review this one I hate missing
made in one okay now what though maybe
check here and I've got to get my knight
out of the way of course I can't I can't
believe I missed mate in one that's
that's embarrassing I'm gonna have to go
back and look at that
let's just continue with the checks for
now if here here
and here we go there's got to be a win
in here somewhere right here and check
and then I can take here I believe do I
give up yeah I guess so and then check
here Oh interesting
maybe just check actually I'll just go
back here save the night there's got to
be checkmate in here somewhere I'm
giving up the think I'm going to protect
here and then I've got to get another
check and this is so close
take here if necessary
Oh God double check this is like really
really tight
oh no damn it
Oh No all right we've got to analyze
that first of all where was the meat in
one I think it was was it around here
five was it after this now I don't even
remember mate in five no I had to have
been after this I was just getting worse
and worse I can't even find the mate in
one when was it maybe there wasn't a
mate in one huh
all right I'm gonna go back to
tournament how do I go back to turn him
in anyway it's just back where's my back
to tournament button Pakman oh here we
go oh there we go
all right wow that that was not that was
not good that was not good I had that I
had that and then I lost it and this
this is why this is why I'm not so good
all right here we go again important not
to get hugely discouraged we're gonna
keep it going that one is that that one
you know that was a tough one that was a
tough one all right same opening is my
first game today oh that's interesting I
think this is the right move
I think here right and then do we
exchange queens or do I check
do I just threaten here I think so man
that last game was not good that last
game was not good okay so yeah all right
there we go
all right quick win gotta love it back
to tournament that was a good good one
to get some momentum going again thank
you to know not to anybody thought
somebody signed up on my website there
but nobody did alright here we go let's
keep it going
I am down to rank 100 in this tournament
let's keep it going
I hope that we get we're not getting it
all right we've got like a four kings
going on usually I've had this opening
many times I don't seem to improve but
this is usually the way to play it which
is probably a bad sign
typically take here and then okay I
think I just go back oh no that's the
center fork that's not good right what
is the right move here I think it's just
to attack a piece I've fallen for that
many many times now I can take here
takes here
now what is the right move think I'm in
a castle no I can't castle oh I can't
guess okay do you need to figure out I
want to get back here and then try to
push here wait no that doesn't actually
that does that work no it doesn't work
it doesn't work because the Queen is
pinned maybe here
that I calculated the question is what's
next okay
so the bishop is still stuck kind of
like the idea of getting the bishop here
well maybe do I lose anything if I do
this and then if I take what it takes
for the Queen I think this is okay think
if here here then here I think right
attack the rook then I can take this
pawn I think still defended this is
undefended though that's the only issue
now if I were let's just think this
through if I go and attack the Queen
takes here that doesn't really work it
just doesn't work
I think I take this this is this is
risky this is very very risky so now
this pawn is undefended and this pawn is
undefended right problem is now the
night becomes undefended as well think
here not good not good I mean I don't
really have any move right it's just
this and then I lose and then I guess I
have to here here actually let's go here
first this one's not going super well as
you can probably tell maybe take this
one keep it going
oh I've kind of fought my way back I'm
way down on time but actually how fought
my way back a little bit kind of like
the idea of this right here anybody
interested in that see what happens so
probably has to move ah
is there any way to force having to
defend against mate okay maybe I go
right after the Queen then take problem
as this square is inaccessible because
of this let's see what we've got
I think I just have to take the Queen
yeah and then go right after here and
then here here let's see what can happen
in the back here now not not happening
okay let's go here try to double up
getting very very low on time
I think I just go here let me think
about this take here this one can't move
oh that was a mistake I think I think my
opponent just made a mistake can I
capitalize on it with only 13 seconds
that was a mistake we're taking here
taking here oh it's all falling apart
but do I have enough time think I'm
taking this one's gonna be tight
it's gonna be a scramble we're gonna
have to keep playing here we'll go here
I think we might have it we might have
it and you keep pushing here there's
probably some easy mate here which I'm
unaware of let's see here can I find it
though can I find it let's just keep
going
Queen
this may be it this may be it
there it is who thought I thought I was
gonna lose that one again I need a
breather after that one alright what's
going on here let's see Ryan clue just
grabbed a membership on my website and
is number seven Thank You Ryan very very
much appreciate that thank you too tit a
18 okay all right guys okay for signing
up on twitch very much appreciate that
and not too much else happening here all
right let's go back to the tournament
what a day what a day we have someone
with 31 points where am i right now out
of seven hundred and eight players
ninety-six that's that's really not bad
that's really I mean I can't be too
upset with that my phones blowing up by
the way I have a bunch of friends
playing in this tournament
everybody's going completely insane
right now all right here we go
let's try to get another win here I
don't know where destiny is anybody know
where what position Destiny's in all
right so this I've had a bunch of times
I usually go for the Queen and then go
back oh okay interesting
then here castle
mmm I usually take here and then here
hmm interesting
actually not quite so sure now I'd love
to get the Queen over here since we've
got action as they say maybe I can start
here and then come over
see what lted ball does so anybody know
how no destiny is number 87 okay
how is producer Pat doing does anybody
know I'm kind of not loving this Bishop
here but now I don't think I can take it
let's get over here
I think this is where I want to be I'm
just thinking just thinking out loud
then probably here could be here but
then oh no the Queen would then be
exposed that wouldn't work think about
that
my opponents thinking that's something
okay
so now I really can't so this this is
just a trade I don't know that I really
gain anything with that but at the same
time if I move the Queen if I attack
there now that doesn't work I think I'm
gonna take only to save some calculation
time and then just try to come up with
something this pawn is now boy that's
actually trouble that's actually trouble
actually maybe I just go no do I move or
do I go right after I come and I'll move
over here that this is probably not the
right move and then maybe this yeah
magic if I got matched up against Steven
Kenneth destiny Bunnell so let's let's
figure this out if I go here can't
really take because it's mate in one
right let's just try it let's try it and
see what happens it looks like a free
night but I don't think this player is
gonna fall for it oh there it is well
that's oh no I can't do that oh no no no
I can't do that so if I go here I lose
the Queen oh boy good thing I just gave
away the Queen which we don't want to do
still can't move there so I think now I
go after the I think I'm gonna go after
the bishop this way
yeah but then I I think I don't I come
out losing because of this so here I
lose a queen loses a rook then they lose
oh actually that's not bad
mm-hm that's interesting that's
interesting
okay so this seems like a free night a
bishop so I think I'm gonna take I think
I take the free bishop right and then
another bishop
and now what is the question maybe just
go after the Queen goes to the Queen now
I can move over here maybe trying to put
something together with the limited time
I have left I kind of am liking this
oh that's I don't think that works
I think just here did I just miss
something big I think I might have
missed something big I'm gonna have to
analyze that now looking at some bank
back rank stuff I think I might just
start moving my king out I'm actually
unsure what the right play is here and
I'm way down on time I'm gonna go oh
this is not good
I'm just gonna go here here and take it
if necessary oh boy here take here that
was a disaster
absolute disaster total disaster
implosion total implosion oh my goodness
what an absolute and total implosion
still even somehow though but not about
to be complete and total implosion
terrible terrible Oh miss the free rook
there but wow wow just with the time
pressure that was a difficult one
has to keep checking right maybe now I
get a check in here not so good
not so good oh boy that was that was
really unfortunate that was let me look
go back and look at the analysis board
there that was not good hold on where
did it happen
okay so here I was winning oh my god
what an idiot so the move here was just
to play the pawn up okay so if I play
the pond doubling up I can take here
take and then take yeah okay well
certainly would have been a fight
certainly would have been a fight there
Wow Wow
okay let's go back to the tournament see
who's winning not surprisingly erik has
rocketed into sixth place with just six
minutes to go let's see if I can get one
more win in here that would be great oh
yeah people saying they think that I
pointing out which my big mistake was
there were any number of big mistakes
there were there was no shortage of big
mistakes though there all right here we
go so here's actually a center fork
which is interesting
okay now pinned
yeah I don't know how to set it up to
play against destiny in the last let's
go right after the Queen in the last
game okay I mean this is my typical
repertoire here so here I've got the
Queen here I've got the Queen here I
don't hear I don't hear I do okay
interesting we're gonna move here then
try to castle out of the way of this
insanity see where this goes hmm
do I castle first now there's two pieces
here this is actually dangerous I think
I need to be safe and go here I think I
think it could have gotten ugly if I did
not defend on this square you can end up
with a pretty nasty fork here okay so
far it's okay was expecting that would
love to end with a win let's see if we
can make it happen I think I'm just
gonna Castle now we'll go for the Queen
for some kind of action like the idea of
this just to get get things going a
little crazy so there any kind of
discovered and check there there is not
actually I'm sure here here it's
starting to get a little questionable
here thanks to everybody gifting subs on
Twitch by the way I appreciate that I'm
gonna have to just go back
is there right that's not so good
that's not so good is there any hmm yeah
that's not good I guess I just missed a
whole lot if I take the rook oh the
Queen's defend it I'm an idiot the
Queen's that what was I worried about
the Queen is defended this entire time I
thought I couldn't do that but the Queen
was did see this is the type of stuff I
miss unbelievable the Queen was defended
the entire time sometimes I just never
imagined there's going to be an
undefended piece left on the board in
that way so this this square now becomes
a very very big focus this pawn is
pinned is there a defense here I guess I
take the Queen so now where is the where
is checkmate
I think I come in here there must be
checkmate somewhere right here I have to
get this out of the way where is
checkmate I'm genuinely unsure how do I
even defend that maybe I just
counter-attack for now and trade here
and here at some point I should probably
get my rooks together trade ok free pawn
and then here defend this oh no I'm an
idiot
what am i doing that was stupid that was
really really stupid
so now we'll defend here now I'll try to
that wood that was actually dumb but I'm
gonna stack up the rooks and now see
what we can do problem is this pawn will
end up undefended oh not if I take here
is this pawn off to the races I'm
actually not sure here here
I think I can keep going right this is
that I never know how to calculate these
here so wait now what do I do I guess I
move one closer this should be a win but
I just am not good enough to know
exactly how maybe a check would that
help me low on time see if we can finish
this out with a win check and then just
take it now and oh boy that's not good
let's go here here it's gonna have to go
that way oh boy that's not good
actually now what do I do this is
actually not oh okay I think I'm okay
wait a second what do I do here check
no that was wrong that was a bad idea
this is a pattern I should be able to do
this can go across the board right can
you believe this I forget what the
patter what it wouldn't but I just need
be really be studying these is that a
time though right
take they're here what a mess
alright now we've we've got to get this
thing wrapped up now right I mean this
is like crazy okay here we go
oh geez this is not good wait a second
this is getting crazy all right we're
just gonna start moving the pond now
here we go what a mess my friends this
has gotta be it right this has got to be
it there it is oh my goodness can you
imagine all right back to the tournament
Eric Rosen Wow holy [ __ ]
Eric Rosen has won the second of two
David Pakman show chess tournaments that
is he is two for two miles the miasmic
coming in second say goo Santos for
coming in third out of 730 people I
ended up 150 third that's really not bad
that's really not bad and I do want to
see that lat I would love to look at
that last game let me see if I can do it
somehow okay let's see if we can look at
that last game so I probably had some
opportunity to win very early on right
right like at all of these points I had
a mate in three item eight and two so at
this point I had made into if I went
here and then oh man
all right well listen a win is a win and
I still ended up I still have that ended
up with with a win there now where did
destiny end up I think destiny probably
did better than me I mean I was going
back and analyzing games also I wasn't
really playing like the fastest oh let's
see
destiny is it Omni destiny there it is
Omni destiny ended up 146 okay so we
were actually pretty close we were
actually pretty close that's really not
bad oh he's still playing that's
interesting no it doesn't seem like he
is wow wow wow wow what an evening
listen I want to thank Michael Turner
who just grabbed a membership on my
website new member number eight of the
day I want to say thanks to Drew GU who
sent a super chat and said I'm the one
that's been begging for the tournaments
thanks
I finished 52nd all right I have all
sorts of people challenging me now
someone rate okay someone rated 21:32
wants to play against me do you guys
want me to play against someone rated
2130 to do and get crushed I mean I
guess I'd be willing to do it I don't
know people are saying yes last skin has
subscribed on Twitch might easy man has
gifted a subscription all right let's do
it I'll play against I'd never even
played against someone this good let's
just see what happens let's see what
happens it's a special evening it's a
special evening we're going to do it
alright Queens gambit declined so far I
think I know what I'm doing I like how
people are trash-talking like Oh David
you're gonna end up losing of course I'm
gonna lose I'm playing against someone
rate rated 2100 all right
I usually play here yeah Dunn says
they're a big fan appreciate that okay
I mean this is all theory I'm sure for
this person I'm playing against castle
bring the knight out I think I'm gonna
take maybe start moving some pawns
I'll take and then play here this feels
to me like it's just all okay so hold on
I think I like this idea better okay
sort of thinking about here or here hmm
maybe just here no no that's what I was
almost gave away a rook there let's go
here Oh No pawn maybe
oh now Eric's rating thanks Erik Erik
won the my two of two tournaments that
I've run erik has now won welcome to
everybody I don't actually know what I'm
doing just so people I talk about
politics so this is just like a novelty
we've done a couple tournaments and now
I'm about to get crushed by someone so I
can't even really move here where do
what do I do
so what about this this this does that
get me anything I keeps me alive so
let's try it
what a day what a day destiny wants 1v1
oh boy when I added listen Destiny's
fine doesn't destiny have like a
socialist to complain about or something
okay that's a good move
that's a good move what should I be
doing got to move the Queen this and all
of these this is all done can't go there
go here don't know what that really gets
me I think that's what I think that's
the move right now and I mean listen at
this point I think I keep trading if I
get the opportunity it's it's you know
it's an honor just to even be in this
okay that was done that was done maybe
not hold on so let's think if I go here
oh I think I can I think this is my best
move I want to analyze this this may
actually be my best move because
obviously if takes I get the Queen okay
oh no oh no this is checkmate isn't it
is I think I didn't need something going
and I think it's checkmate because if I
take the Queen that's it right oh no no
I can go no what am I talking about I
can go over here
now it's a pawn fight can I even make it
now Wow Wow
alright I resign listen I've got to be
happy with my performance so let's see
where was that where was that move I
wanted to analyze it was when I had a
bishop hold on here okay so I moved here
the right move actually I mean this move
was not so bad like I fell another half
point behind but it was not the worst
move I actually should be pleased with
that interesting okay well listen I mean
I never would have would have figured
out any of these other moves but I
actually I should not be that upset
would this move because it was not
disastrous it was not disastrous people
saying I should have played the pawn
earlier okay excellent very very good it
seems like everybody is all straightened
out all right guys that's gonna do it
really appreciate everybody who played
we will do this again maybe next month
sick what was that anybody know where
can I see the total number of people
that played let me see where we were at
where was that tournament oh man I have
hold on david pakman.com slash chess i
want to know what our total was 7:30
okay so 730 people total ended up
playing which is definitely the high
mark and something definitely to to
cheer about I have 7 different
challenges right now ok I think I think
I've probably played enough chess for
one evening my friends 730 people it's
very late in the evening for our viewers
in Europe I appreciate everybody who
joined me if you are watching on twitch
do give me a follow it's free it's free
on Twitch and I've only been on Twitch
about 10 months and we're trying to
build it up if you're watching on
YouTube of course always welcome I'll
probably
tomorrow I'm guessing we'll have a
Kaylie maghen a now press briefing so
I'll see everybody tomorrow thanks for
joining me
you